[Music]
so
recently a chinese reality show
uh went viral for all the wrong reasons
uh-oh last month it was christmas
right and uh they decided to do a
christmas
special on a uh on a particular show and
say
who's the murderer so it's like a
reality show where they merry christmas
exactly has nothing to do with christmas
by by the way nothing to do with
christmas
and uh they're it's a show about how
people can figure out how murderers
like or like it sounds like mafia
honestly how we used to play mafia
yeah seems like they're playing some
version of that kind of game
oh like a murder mystery game yes oh
those are fun the light goes off and
then you're like
ah somebody died who did it merry
christmas
merry christmas and so for and this is
the
the most ironic thing so mango tv's
named the television
uh uh station and they decided that
since
it's christmas we might as well do a
christmas special so they rented out
a hotel that's decked out in christmas
uh [ __ ] everywhere
it's got a big tree it's got you know
lights everywhere
they've even told the cast to show up
with some christmas you know
uh wardrobe sounds just like jk party
sounds just like jk party it does and
they were like oh you know
it's festive might as well make it
festive cut to
when they're editing the video oh no
they're like all right well
you know we are a chinese television uh
uh television station and you know there
is a
like a you know i guess in chinese
culture like right now like under the
communist rule that you should try to
promote
chinese values in chinese culture and if
you promote any western
things it comes off like you're
promoting
foreigners and that's kind of like
frowned upon uh
in the eyes of the chinese government
that's why i was wondering like
was christmas a thing in china that's
why the whole yeah the whole time i was
like i didn't know that they celebrated
isn't
religion also like kind of like they
shun away from look thinking about
religion in the chinese government
yes so like religion's more or less not
cool
in china but this is the government
speaking though
so i'll i'll get into that after this
let me show you some pictures of what
ended up being
the the tv show oh my god i can't wait
i knew it the whole thing is just blurry
funny
they blurted everything out they blurred
everything the irony
hey it's christmas let's celebrate
christmas let's we should make it
festive
they rent out a hotel that's decked in
christmas stuff
cut to editing they say oh let's blurt
it all out we shouldn't promote it
wow and this is the final product they
ended up with
because the government official probably
had to approve this and they were like
perfect we erased all christmas things
there was no government it sucks and i
even think about all this
the government officials didn't actually
come in and say no the
the tv people were just like oh we
should also be like good chinese people
again and try to you know do what you
know the government want us to do so
they decided to blur
everything out did the government come
out you're in the spring you have to do
this
uh well it didn't they didn't maybe
unofficially
maybe they didn't want to get in trouble
so they did it previously they're like
we're gonna christmas
but we're gonna like give them an idea
it's like japanese porn
right like it's like let me get an idea
of what it is
so i could use my imagination on how
beautiful that tree is
but i want to know if the government
came out and was like we're gonna have
to do this
like probably but even japanese porn
they don't like
exactly like pixelate the whole body
this is like
everything the whole room's pixelated
the only thing you can figure is
the two of three people standing here
you can still tell it's a christmas tree
so distracting
what i mean look at this guy i don't
know what's the imagination and think
about the beautiful ornaments
or sparklies i think so why'd they put a
tree on the bottom though oh because
they allowed it because it didn't have
decorations oh no it's a it's a pine
tree
no christmas stuff in america they would
just cancel this [ __ ]
yeah reshoot it yeah so
it went viral it went viral on chinese
media
first that place looks balling as far as
people on weibo
were laughing at it they were basically
saying like
why the [ __ ] did you do this like first
of all in china
people love christmas not very many
christians in china but
they love christmas it's a beautiful
holiday exactly and they love it for all
the reasons that i think most people
love it for it's like it's festive it's
a reason
to get together to celebrate something
you know family spread
all the colors are bright and it's
happening i wonder when christmas came
to china
when christians came to china probably i
don't know i i don't know but christian
christianity and christmas isn't the
same thing but they still bring it
places
true they bring the santa claus to you
because my grandma
um grew up doing christmas [ __ ] too
and i was like how the [ __ ] did this
idea even come to japan
i think it might be the malls i think it
might be like the businesses yeah cause
i went to a christian private school
and for our christmas it was all about
like jesus and the the stable
and then like the three kings or
whatever we're not talking about santa
claus
isn't that interpretation of christmas
super different in japan though because
like
i saw the bar and this he was
celebrating it and in japan it's like
much more of a romance holiday
oh i know they eat kfc yeah yeah they
eat
the green thing and then kfc because
that's like because kfc
they get buckets of chicken and they eat
it that's like that's like their
christmas dinner because uh from what
byron it's american
is that why yeah he was like well their
idea of american would be like
kfc and then it's like when they think
of christmas it's like western
it is yeah because mine and then so they
don't have the chimney
they do believe like the santa claus
thing but they don't have the same story
as of like
hanging your stockings on the chimney
because people don't have chimneys or
whatever right
so like they hide presents around the
house
or like easter yeah but it's like you
wake up and it's like the presence next
to your bed
because santa came and he put it next to
your bedroom and then the parents hire
[ __ ] zombies to scare the kids
and you have japanese santa going home
but yeah so one person on weibo wrote in
our country christians are minorities
a majority the majority see christmas as
a fun festival
the commercial sector finds a reason to
get sales consumers find an opportunity
to spend
lovers find an occasion to reveal their
feelings and make out it has nothing to
do with worshiping the west
the majority do not think that christmas
has anything to do with religion this is
not the way
to build cultural confidence so in
reference to wow
chinese thinking man that's cool chinese
people there that are actually uh
using their critical minds right now
that's a new thing chinese
chinese culture strength is related to
its power to absorb other cultures we
use
we used to accept foreign culture and
make it our own so that our civilization
can move on what have we become now in
reference to
this whole pixelated away from draconian
style
so then after uh the controversy spread
from weibo
to twitter actually made its presence
onto twitter now uh
mango tv the studio decided to call it
vaseline pixelated version off
i decided to pull it and they uploaded
the the non-pixelated version yeah
oh they did nice damn that's crazy yeah
editor's like [ __ ]
man all that [ __ ] work yeah
damn that's so funny i just love how
their level of embarrassment or shame is
just like
so much lower than then or like it's
just so much different than ours here
because like
you can't we can't imagine working for a
company and then having them do
that and then being okay with putting
out a product that looks like that
that's true it's just funny they're more
afraid of the government than we are
that's why
because they doing that because they're
not afraid about what the
their audience would say they're more
afraid of getting in trouble by the
government
yeah whereas us is the opposite we don't
give a [ __ ] our government can
eat ass right and then we're we're just
more afraid of
like our audience feeling like we're not
real
that's true thinking about like
americans it's more like it's
it's it's different it's back it's
different from them yeah
like the government's not gonna crack
down on like
jk news because we said something and
then [ __ ]
put us in jail or like well we can't
say things that can put us in jail there
are things we can say that can put us
into
like reasonably you know we can't
reasonably
like like obviously we can't threaten
and say we're gonna kill someone
and all this stuff right that's
reasonable in my opinion it's reasonable
but then when it comes to like christmas
and sharing the joys of christmas our
government's not going to say like
no [ __ ] that stop talking about
christmas and i'll put you in jail
there is a little bit of that happening
i mean i mean for better for worse like
we're not
supposed to say merry christ like a lot
of companies don't say merry christmas
anymore they say really
uh happy holidays to be inclusive yeah
to be inclusive so there is like a
little bit of like this like christmas
is kind of weird now
we're not gonna but that's not gonna be
about it right now yeah it's back to
saying
that's the audience that they're afraid
of so they're so like companies
like nike taking a stance on like you
know political things or whatever
they're afraid of their audience not the
government
so i think but china's the opposite yeah
like the government's scarier than the
audience that's true so in january
2017 the the central committee of the
chinese communist party and state
council uh uh
kickstarted a new document that suggests
suggestions on implementation of
projects to promote and develop chinese
traditional chinese culture heritage um
asks
all levels of government local doors to
promote chinese festivals and culture so
there is like a
a a thing in uh starting 2017 that
have people promoting chinese culture
and banning foreign things yeah then
when they started banning the hip-hop
stuff and then blurring out like
piercings and on tv and stuff maybe
then maybe i do know that
okay my friend who is chinese
not gonna say his name but like he's
hella against
this campaign because he's like
the citizens there can't differentiate
communist party and china
so now they're merging the two things
together as
as if it's one right so like if you
criticize
the communist party people get pissed
because you're like oh you don't like
chinese people
they're like no no it's not the same
thing it's like it's almost like
ridiculing like
if like if we're talking [ __ ] about
republicans like they're not all amen i
mean that's kind of what
happens here though where you're like
criticizing is going on in the
government at the time and people are
like why don't you just move to a
different country then
you know it's kind of the same right but
the
i guess the issue is out there it's only
one party it's the communist party
that's all
there's no one else so it's like that on
steroids
yeah so like people don't know that when
you criticize it or say certain things
about that
like they're like wait why are you
saying [ __ ] about chinese people
right there's no there's no options in
the way you think
here at least we have two parties right
or two ways of thinking
obviously there's also a lot of great
area for us to like
to maneuver in but in china it doesn't
seem that way yeah i don't know but i'm
really surprised that like on weibo like
there's people actually coming forward
and saying like having an opinion yeah
have an opinion yeah actually
how does that how [ __ ] crazy it is
like we knew
that if you had an opinion in the past
in a communist government you get [ __ ]
up
maybe because now they have anonymity
with with social media
oh maybe yeah but they have they're
brilliant they hack into you and still
find out who you are
i don't know maybe they have their ways
vpns i don't know i feel like
they're just evolving like they're not
like north korea like what we knew of
them
yeah i don't know
[Music]
you